welcome to this video playing da Silva
from the US and I played the English
Defence with b6 yeah he's playing this
in a very restrained fashion not bad Wow
it should be three yeah this is quite
uncommon let's grab the center cannot be
bad
hmm yeah or develop Bishop d3 is just a
somewhat we had moved
yeah 95 ready this kind of bullet style
attack okay so just take it along many
ways to play can also play g6 first and
send this Bishop home and let's just
take this is simple and good and Bishop
basics next
check
yeah I've got night before coming right
before d3 rc2 I need to retreat all the
way back here to to be one was he do
yeah to be run okay still still night
before is an idea I can play that and
play will be a next winning a temple
sooo
okay let's get grab the temple here
first and then see how to proceed night
b5 officer his idea
I can always some just go igo sidestep
this
wait wait wait wait I can think about I
can think about what Nyjah for hear even
it's not completely ridiculous about g3
and I can play g3 ok so let's get out of
the night be five idea at least them I
mean in a way that it is really hurting
me so be sure to be full or not yes got
95 okay
hmm yeah it
makes a fairly solid impression for
white
I whoopsie one was like that and is
probably okay here the bishop is not
doing much on a six anyway
hmm
yeah it should be 5mm don't want to get
directly into the spin
thank you p 95 nine
yeah this night needs to go cannot
tolerate it on honey 5 all the time so
what do we have here is symmetrical
position
Bishop to b6 I want to play that
covering before yeah at the end us will
get some some some time stuff because of
the position is fairly equal I think and
check okay yeah I got the two bishops
always like that but it's probably not
not good for any any advantage
yeah I can just take it I mean t3 with a
draw okay maybe maybe I can get
something mp3 yeah never underestimate
the two ships it's almost checkmate here
check
check
yeah amazing how quickly this is
deteriorated for white
check
time warning check check check check
mate gotta like the two bishops but okay
somehow he screwed this up it should
have been a drone really in the same
game it should be at wrong like this
this must be drawn some how was he he
allowed something they had 95 of course
this was a problem this just blunders
this is Pawn if he doesn't do that it's
nothing going on like something here is
no way for me to make any progress it's
just the drawn I always need to tend to
the before weakness and yeah after that
it just just over basically alright
thanks for watching